after 20 years in Parliament to the
serving and governments of Tony Blair
and Gordon Brown the former Home
Secretary Allen Johnson is stepping down
from his seat in Hull at this election I
had a huge amount of respect for Allen
Johnson but now that he's decided to go
I think politics there needs shaking up
we are currently coming on to the
streets that I was born and bred and in
a moment we will be passing fairy house
that I was born in
one of the reasons I want to support
this constituency is this is my life
[Music]
hey I'm Michele Dewberry amongst other
things I spend a lot of time talking
about politics
I'm therefore gonna stand as an
independent candidate in my home
constituency which is Hall West and
Hazel I'm gonna align myself with the
Tories on brexit but I'm gonna stand for
the best interest of that constituency
beyond that politics should not just be
reserved for the big boys
every general election people from all
over the UK pay 500 pounds to stand as
an independent candidate few are ever
successful with only 5 weeks to Election
Day and with no party behind a
businesswoman and pledge panelists
Michelle do Bri decides to join them
who's this what money win you know what
I'm doing I want to be your MP do you
not know him he is what is it you don't
know what it is I'd say wait it being an
MP means I'm gonna come after ya
Michelle is catching up with her makes
some brother-in-law I was just sitting
there thinking what if someone wants to
vote who they actually going to vote for
because I think caliber people avert
labor just was like they feel like the
shores but labour just let everybody
down then I think like round here I
think you've got loads of people in
honest but probably won't vote in a
general election
yeah because I know that when I was
around here I didn't vote until I was 30
years old understanding this Michelle
Dewberry
I'm not labour knocked or a Michelle do
brewery brexit iere I want to say it
speed with your labour but you feel like
letting you down you can come to me well
your voice be aired on as an independent
it is what you only might just be
pointless we might be giving you a job
well there because ultimately our core
just as much of a voice as any other MP
people will be drawn to you because of
your strong personalities obviously
you're very opinionated but the thing is
you got old anything back so what's that
Advil yeah
I love you because I know that but I
know you only works your family and you
sometimes you should never show up so I
know you'd win if anything I think you
could make changes and I'd like to
address Rabia
I swear to Allah Japanese nuclear me
over there yeah you go they promote to a
campaign and things with life but it is
I know Michelle personally will speak up
for you and I know like if if somebody
tries talking down to it just made a
mess right talking down to that quite a
few times and I never wig and never way
and that's not because I'm not Randy
because Michelle's very strong and she
believes and what she's doing is right
and she literally you just you put all
your passion to this I think yeah I feel
strongly about it because one other
thing to say we all know is because I'm
not labor or Tori anything I have no
supports it's just me so anyone's in
hole and can help me spread the word
handing out leaflets chair and stuff
online whatever please I like that you
need all the help he's gonna do some
leaflets make independent candidates
often struggle without a party machine
behind them I'm so pleased that Emma
Hardy is the Labour candidate and I hope
you'll succeed me as the Member of
Parliament for harmless and hazel it was
a clear choice here there was a choice
between the future that you could have
with labour and a future that you could
have with the Tories and they're very
very different
[Music]
isn't about personalities this isn't
about individuals it's about the type of
society that you want to spend the rest
of your life in that's the choice people
have got to make on June 8th so mom yes
I had an interest in the chat I'm gonna
go with this guy I know I've got no - oh
yeah and no team and nothing basically I
had this chat with this guy a second ago
and he's gonna is coming all the way
from down south to hold tomorrow to meet
me and basically what they are they are
this company while campaign group I
guess so they've got some business guide
that's put a lot of money into this fund
and what they want to do is change
Parliament mom they want more
independent candidates and they give ABS
poor they provide people and funding up
so at 10 grand
that's just what you need any track oh
that's brilliant girls I'm really
pleased yeah here we are again out
handing out leaflets again anyway I've
got my mum with me I mean my mum doing
the leaflet in this is if you ever
decide sort of been an independent
candidate for an election this is the
kind of stuff you've got to think
through you're going to be sitting there
and you're going to be spending your
weekends when everyone else is in the
pub you're going to be like this we
leave
around the country politicians continue
on the election trail polls are
predicting a landslide majorities for
tourism ace government I can make you
ice in fact you're poison I hope you get
beat up Logan get sixy oh thank you very
much quickly no okay
despite the campaign being underway
Michelle still needs to register today
the important day so we've got to
deliver the nominations this is my
nomination pack so go deliver a
nomination paper and address form a
consent to nomination I've got to that's
all got to be delivered to so you know
that's all got to be delivered by hand
does it have to be in vodka at all am i
overthinking it why don't have to do on
paper or anywhere why just do it online
god I actually genuinely feel nervous
this is like the weirdest thing I need
to get ten names and addresses of
constituents on the electoral roll plus
a proposal and a seconder original
thinking of using my own family for that
was just because it would have made life
easy for me but I actually don't want my
family's names and addresses publicized
for various reasons so now I'm good I
also just go and find 10 random people
that live in my constituency check them
against the electoral roll to make sure
that they do indeed live there and they
will become my 10 people somewhere to do
that oh by the way I'm obviously doing
something right because my odds have
been flashed as 50 was too pretty to one
before on I'm 25 to one now and I think
that's good I think that means that
people have more faith in me winning is
that right I think it is
mark Adams is from campaign for a free
Parliament a group which supports
independent candidates I'll be living
room is not fine Jeremy storie waddling
to its suitability as a campaign rooms
and get the awesome yeah what about the
history is the history is great comes
not very visible so if you had as often
people do a shop floor a shop space
rather on a high street yeah be hundreds
of people everyday walking up and down
seeing it you don't get that that's a
con
now I'm sufficiently interest in what
you're doing to be happy to get involved
on a voluntary basis I'm effectively
something what I am self-employed so I
can do that on a voluntary basis but I
hope I mean it's working quite well
we've got a good rapport getting so far
I think you can see how I can help
personally and I want you to feel
comfortable just to ask me anytime any
of these big questions that you're
you're worrying about and if I don't
know the answer myself I'll be honest
enough to tell you I don't know the
answer but I'll almost certainly know
somebody who doesn't know the answer you
are obviously the most valuable asset to
this campaign and we're going to use
that asset and that means making sure
you're out visible being seen as much as
possible
let me get your ballot
I get one of those boys gonna give you
one of those I'll give you one of these
please thank you thank you clear that
Thanks I know me shot you reselling the
election this area hello hi you should
just I think you're doing it right
want me to yell well god bless ya thanks
Alan can I give you one of those thank
you give it every day what's what
whatever yeah let's get more football
right lions tigers
[Applause]
with just hours to go before
registration closes she visits an old
school friend to get her last nomination
so what it is it's basically to say and
you live in my my area base in my
constituency and you nominate me as a
candidate so you're you want me to stand
as a candidate a Dhulia so the trust and
you how tightly about I've inserted I
think if inside it no motive earth but
no notice they go somewhere excited her
for me
what's one I've got the absolute
deadline is four but I've got to get it
in before that son get the thing check I
don't even got my bloody deposit this is
what I'm saying
the make it difficult it is 2017 why I
can't just go in and put D Y at the comb
a PDQ machine why can't use my card why
do I have to wander in we banknotes
I can get something to quit
[Music]
I'm gonna go into my bank into my bank
okay remember last time I went into a
bang honestly I swear to god Ryan
politics needs younger blood fresh blood
but in my head the system it's just
bloody skewered towards an older
generation young if you want young blood
into politics the entire system needs
shaking up
I've got bloody God knows how many pages
of paper there to shuffle through to get
people's details
I've got everything some bits of paper
I've got go knocking on bloody doors
handing out bits of paper for my face on
it then I've got going hand in bits
appear Perth to pay for my stuff and
then if you want to vote for me you've
got to go and sand bits of paper we're
not living a bit of paper society we
live in a digital age it's actually
frustratingly early now that I actually
think about it seriously is
onwards and upwards let's register to be
a member of parliament
[Applause]
[Music]
jeremy corbyn's campaign gains momentum
as he draws massive crowds at his
rallies across the UK
[Music]
[Applause]
hols finest export labor in Hull today
and all the spending on Jeremy Corbyn
being here we'll all come out of their
national spending then it not penny of
that will be allocated to Emma Hardy's
election expenses but clearly he's here
to try and benefit her campaign hands up
who's done
door knocking canvassing before yay hey
come on and hands up three hundred doors
that's our target for tonight okay there
is a script which I'm going to give to
all of you I'm calling on behalf of
Michelle Dupree your independent
candidate in the general election 8th of
June we're calling to give people an
opportunity to meet Michelle and hear
any concerns you have for the area can I
just ask you some questions right are we
ready yes I'm a whole girl I'm standing
for election in this area I'm a
breakfast here and I voted for bricks it
and I want to make it happen and I just
want to change politics in the city okay
my have a lot we're out door knocking
we've got a light good squad going on
just knowing that people are backing me
and knocking on the doors for me it
feels brilliant with me independent are
purely insignia represent fallen hazel
but I'll be cherry-picking the best bits
of all the different parties we all
agree on the same kind of issues want
good schools put good careers a decent
NHS we all agree but then what happens
is everyone starts arguing about
political colors and passes who did you
vote for up oh about me yeah she's
my daughter but last time and I was
gonna vote for me let's get those laser
burns yeah
[Music]
back in the office a setback to the
campaign over what to call the
constituency so every candidate gets a
royal mail drop and election
communication they call it and how it
works is that the govern the Romell do
one free personal drops it's super
important because realistically exact
got loads and loads of volunteers all
time this is going to be my one
opportunity to make sure that every
single house gets a communication from
me so what you have to do it's quite
stringent you have to design all your
artwork it's got have all this stuff on
it it's got us there various things it's
really strict and so we've spent ages
getting it all right it's basically like
my standard you know I'm sound of
branding and I've just on it rejected
yeah
okay all right okay thanks very much
yeah thanks thanks bye bye it's really
astonishing because they've they've
accepted they made a mistake and they've
let labour through they've recorded by
the wrong name and and I said well easy
solution make it fair let us right now
but that would still be wrong and you
know two wrongs don't make a right and
so I'm obviously two wrongs don't make
it right but it's just a question of
having some bloody common sense
[Music]
I've got my first ever hosting today
I've never heard that word before but
apparently just a bit it will be
interesting because it's my first one
that I've got another two so I'll use it
as a practice and yeah let's see how it
goes
look welcome to another hot topic
election special once again from the
Magnificent Guildhall in Howell this
term I'm with the candidates for Hull
West and Hessel I am standing purely and
simply for the people of Hall West and
Hazel I've had enough of politicians no
offense I just had enough of politics in
the way it is the NHS is a bottomless
pit isn't it is that there is not a top
amount of money that you can invest in
the NHS we should all pay a penny extra
on our tax in order to make sure we've
got a well-funded NHS clay your attitude
frustrates me because what you're
talking about is more money for the NHS
more money for the NHS what actually
needs to happen in the NHS is a proper
review of is this system fit for purpose
the way it is is the right funding going
into the right places
oh thank you
well why did this come from the other
better so you ever get nervous like
chicken huh not chicken
sorry I think I know what it is oh yeah
I know it is okay
hey now we're talking kids - sure it's
bad boy yes I'm sick I'm not about to
die so that says hey this is what one of
my supporters has made me yes do you
think she can win it's still a huge
mountain to climb but before I thought
it was almost impossible now I think
it's highly unlikely which is an obvious
improvement
[Music]
it's skills like this it will be the
apprentice Ginetta
[Music]
we spend like 11 or 13 billion pounds a
year on administration in the government
so to me there's so much wasted
[Music]
you shouldn't have to be selling the
houses and stuff like that and not being
able to pass something down wrong
no I don't want the Labour Party what
would success post brexit look like to
this community
you
I thought any scissors to even cut those
things right okay let's go let's go
before let's go before someone
recognizes us
this thing is gonna collapse there's so
many issues that I feel passionate about
and at the same time feeling passionate
about disliking politics and all of the
dishonesty in the games that are part of
it at the moment
and I just think when you change it's
time for some freshness maybe do you so
how much baggage Oliver just don't try
and convince yeah you're gonna ever
really do well I bet will you bet me
yeah
will ya tight even tell you how much I
appreciate it thank you yeah thanks see
a time marks making final preparations
the night before Election Day stage well
um probably I wouldn't start from here
isn't is the honest answer but we are
where we are we've got 5,000 leaflets
we're very very roughly trying to target
them in the areas where we found most
support for Michelle to make sure that
in those areas they get a leaflet
tomorrow just reminding them that
Michelle's getting to is it on the
ballot paper and to come out and vote
for her so that's that's our priorities
to get those leaflets out that the
established parties will be knocking on
doors from very early tomorrow morning
because there they'll have got a lot
further with all their volunteers
identifying where their vote is and will
be knocking on doors that people have
said they're supporting we found
supporters but we haven't just don't
have the resources to go knocking on
those doors now to say to those people
come out and come out and vote so
instead we we have to do it this way and
just hope that they take the hint when
we put a leaflet nicely fit in their
door telling them to to do it they will
love it they will love it so that's the
priority - there was a second there's a
second priority he's never experienced
anything so organized and
entrepreneurial in his life we go with
the flow it's exciting and it's gonna be
a new challenge yeah um I was sort of
trying to say something like that wasn't
I yeah absolutely
I just don't know let anybody down I
think people have trusted me and they
won't change they really want change
and anybody that's voted for me you know
that it goes in here and it means
something and I am humbled by it and I
don't let them down so we'll see what
tomorrow bringing is cut where point
everybody are we doing
welcome to the Lake District
there is less than six minutes to go now
until voting ends at 10 o'clock which is
of course when we can bring you the
results of that exit poll we will be
bringing you live results from Jewsbury
from Hull and from Sheffield as well
so the ballot boxes will start arriving
from all the polling stations
very soon after 10:00 the first thing
that happens once they're checked in is
their verified which means they count
the number of ballot papers just to make
sure that the tallies with the number
that's expected to be there then they'll
start counting them into piles for each
candidate yes sir there are three
constituencies being counted in the
guild hall as a different room for each
count and there will be a series of
tables and there are the tellers the
people who are counting you can keep an
eye on how these piles are stacking up
and that will give us a fairly good idea
of where you are it's been an
extraordinary night of results so far
21,000 defeating like salmon has been
defeated in Gordon's that's it is great
massive win for the Labour Party Sophie
a seismic shock going through the nation
and now the moment of truth I in
Anderson being the acting returning
officer for the parliamentary election
King step on hold West and hassle to
hear but I give notice the number of
votes recorded for each candidates is as
follows do Bri Michelle Louise Fay
independent 1898 Hardy Emma and Labour
Party 18,000
[Applause]
an I do therefore hereby declare that
Emma and Hardy is duly elected member of
Parliament's Thank You Aurora I really
appreciate it
we take picture of me and my mommy yeah
five and a half percent of the vote in
the end and I'm so proud I can tell ya
brilliant to get my deposit back I think
I was entirely diluted when I came into
it because I genuinely with my hand on
my heart I could win genuinely it's been
an amazing exhausting exhilarating
experience but it's only for the brave I
think it's only for the brave I've got
massive amounts of respect that anybody
that does their
you